Okay, I hope you're able to get this one right. The answer is variant 1 would
be more significant, and the reason is that
this mutation or variation, this change from a
C to an A, changes the codon from CTG, here's C T or U. G, which would
be a leucine right, the second amino acid was leucine, to an ATG, which would be
AUG or methianine. So now we change from a leucine up here to a methianine down
here. Leucine to methianine. But in this variation going from a CTG to a TTG.
If we look over here, t. So u and then u and then g. You'll notice is still
a lusine. This codon is still a lusine just like that codon up there.
So where as this is a variation, a change
from the cytosine to the thiamine. The codon is
different, but the overall amino acid produced from it
is still leucine. So this is not going to be
nearly as significant a change as this one here,
where we get a different amino acid entirely. Remember
structure is function in the chemical world, and we
just changed the structure. Of our overall protein because
we change the amino acid.